one of the philosophers who many people
don't generally include is very
important in the Canon but who I find
very important in my own work I use him
a lot not only in terms of understanding
philosophical movements in an academic
sense but also in a very practical way
in my coaching and and work with with
individuals is Marcus Tullius Cicero and
he's somebody who has grown on me over
the years I think that he is not
sufficiently appreciated and that has
its roots I'll talk a little bit where
that came from you know it has its roots
in I think the 19th century and and how
philosophy and its history have been
looked at many people think of Cicero as
kind of a you know secondary derivative
thinker he's not as important to say
Plato Aristotle or or indeed the late
Stoics or Epicurus but I actually think
that he deserves to be placed up there
at the you know top level I think that
in addition to doing a lot of great work
as a translator and as a person
interpreting reinterpreting classic
philosophy he has some interesting ideas
of his own as well and I find myself
particularly attracted to him you know
at this stage in my life and career
because of his eclecticism and the way
in which he has articulated though how
what kind of eclectic he is and I talked
about that in another video so I will
come back to that but let me talk first
about how myself I got into Cicero and
developed a greater appreciation for him
over time so I actually have one of the
volumes that I first read by Cicero this
isn't the actual volume the actual
volume was in the Southern Illinois
University Library but this is the Loeb
series and as I was working on my Latin
you know and essentially doing it on my
own there's a whole story there you can
hear about in one of my other videos I
got to the point where I realized that I
needed to start reading other
reading authors not just reading little
snippets of them and so I thought well
you know Cicero he's an important guy
let me go to the library and I'm looking
through his different works and I saw
this one the academics and the academics
is a dialogue between several different
representatives of different
philosophical schools and I thought that
sounds really it sounds really cool I'll
check that out
Cicero is very tough to read in Latin
still is for me today although my level
is much higher than it was then and it
took me going through the semester took
me about the entire semester to get my
way through ten pages and these are not
you know particularly long pages I
notice ten pages where Latin is on one
side English on the other so you can
actually do some points of comparison it
took me a long time to get through that
and I was like boy maybe I bit off more
than I can chew I'll come back to Cicero
later on but I read the work and I was
really impressed with the fact that
Cicero could take a lot of people's
ideas and represent them in ways that I
knew were because I'd read other things
about you know Stoics Aristotelians
academic sceptics you know Epicureans
we're largely faithful to what they had
to say and he was also giving us
interesting background and reflections
on the Roman situation and in terms of
culture and the backstory so that was my
real introduction to Cicero and I
continued reading his works off and on
he wasn't somebody who we had to read in
our classes or in the massive reading
list for our comps and prelims but he
was somebody who I was reading and then
when I had the opportunity to start you
know teaching ancient philosophy first
at Indiana State Prison I taught that
class twice and then you know in other
other venues and also you know to
smuggle stuff into my intro classes I
started teaching Cicero's texts and you
can actually see videos where
I'm looking at his dialogue on
friendship or on the nature of the gods
I think those are the main ones that I
did but there's a lot of other great
works I actually brought several of them
here that I love going back to over and
over again Cicero's on duties which is
representing stoic philosophy the de
finibus are on the ends where he's got a
great dialogue going on between
representatives of several different
philosophical schools and even the
people who aren't being represented
directly they're being discussed so
Aristotelian Oh classic politeness as
opposed to academic platanus are being
represented there and so what I really I
mean this is a great jumping-off point
what I really like about Cicero is that
his dialogues are genuine you know
exchanges of view between people and and
it's guaranteed usually that the
epicurean is gonna lose Cicero is not
always completely fair to the Epicureans
representing them at their strongest
points but he does provide us with so
much you know great background and sort
of exposition of what the schools think
it turns out that that becomes
incredibly valuable for us given how
much of literature that we've lost from
classical antiquity so we know a lot
about the Stoics in part through Cicero
who is not himself a a stoic but who had
studied under Stoics who engaged with
them pretty routinely even fought side
by side with him if you think about you
know Cato in the Civil Wars and he is
good at at putting across what their
position is and then going into the
minutiae and explaining it if he hadn't
done that we would be at a severe
disadvantage we would also be at a
severe disadvantage in terms of the
Epicureans as well and we learn a lot
about the Aristotelian 's of his time
and how they saw you know the interplay
between say philosophy and rhetoric or
any of these these sorts of things as
well one of the other facets of Cicero's
work that I particularly admire and
enjoy is the fact that he is he's a
practical philosopher he was engaged in
political life in a number of different
ways in part through his arguing cases
as a jurist right and so he understands
that rhetoric is not only useful for its
own sake or interesting for its own sake
but that it has this a very important
social implication in terms of a house
you know how the laws are applied or not
applied he actually goes so far as to
write a thing about electioneering which
is quite interesting but regarded by
many as being very cynical in the lower
case C not not the upper case C which
was a actual philosophical school and
and what I see in Cicero is his capacity
to call out the practical implications
of schools like say the playtest one
that we might see as very impractical
and to drive this stuff home to talk
about well what would be the effects of
this he he's not the kind of person who
thinks that philosophers ought to simply
engage in their own leisure that they
they should be politically engaged and
involved especially if they're you know
in situations where they they could
exercise some power for good or for bad
he saw his own writing project and this
is another important point from where I
sit he saw his own project of writing
all these books as a massive and major
contribution to Latin culture in a way
he you might say that he occupies a
similar role to oh a theist coming
centuries later at the beginning of what
we call the dark ages
Boethius had decided to translate all of
Plato and Aristotle into Latin from from
Greek he didn't succeed in that because
he was executed before that but but
Cicero talks about taking all of the the
wisdom of the Greek philosophers and
even orders and sort of putting it into
a Latin idiom and he was he was very
critical of the people of his own time
who were skeptical of this who are
saying well you
do philosophy and Latin you know it has
to be done in Greek sort of like we have
people today who say well you're not
really reading Meech if you don't if
you're reading him in translation if you
if you can't use the the German terms
instead of English terms you're not
really understanding it and sister would
say that's bunk the test for whether you
really do understand it can you put it
into your own language and I'm gonna do
that he says and he does do it you know
he he could have accomplished more of
course I think but you know we can say
that about anybody and what he did
accomplish is pretty massive we've lost
a few of his treatises unfortunately and
some of them are fragmentary but what we
do have is a very substantive body of
work that I think is I put it out it's
great because we learn about these these
great schools and what they thought
often down to very detailed analyses and
minutiae but it's also Cicero showing
his own hand a good bit at the time
so let me talk a little bit about his
his eclecticism it's a very reasoned
very measured eclecticism he thinks that
it is important to know the field and
then to select what you think is
actually right he does in fact identify
himself with the academic school but
he's not a rigorous academic skeptic in
the sense of being Orthodox and saying
nothing can really be known or anything
like that he is just as willing to draw
on the Peripatetic or Aristotelian
tradition or the Platonic tradition or
especially the stoic tradition like I
mentioned you know on Duty's is entirely
a work of stoic philosophy with a little
bit of stuff mixed in and in the
Tusculum disputations he actually says
if I was not a member of the school that
I'm a member of I definitely would be a
stoic so he's somebody who is willing to
try to synthesize the best in all of
these different modes of thought which i
think is a very admirable quality it's
not just like eclectic in the sense of
you know there's a nice smorgasbord in
front of me and I'm gonna pick little
bits and pieces and not try to make them
actually match up with each other he is
really thinking through what are the
Stoics right about
where where do things go wrong and he
gives you reasons for this and he has
characters often exchanging and views
and criticizing each other's points of
view
on this very matter so I mean these are
all things that I find just fascinating
about his work the last thing I'll say
is why I mentioned at the beginning that
he's not really held in high esteem even
today and definitely wasn't during the
19th century
why not because they were they were
telling this story of philosophy that
now we know is really not all that true
which is that you know philosophy arises
in the Greek city-states
and it's primarily important in you know
what Plato and Aristotle do and then
with the Stoics and the academics and
and the Epicureans do it's kind of
second-rate it's it's not really as you
know important as what these guys are
doing and then you know people like like
you know Plutarch and Cicero these these
people bringing things together and
eclectic fashions they're really not
that important at all they're not doing
anything original and I think that
that's really bunk I think we have a we
need a different conception of
originality and we need to have
different standards of value I think if
we if we actually adopted a Ciceronian
standard of value we might say I don't I
don't think we would say that he's more
important than Aristotle or Plato but I
think we would say that he really does
deserve to be on the same level I know
that he certainly does for me and I am
looking forward to years and years and
years of having him as a companion as I
read through his works and talk about
them with others and teach them so I
thought I would share some of that with
with you and now you know a little bit
more about my own philosophical
development and commitments at least
with respect to Marcus Tullius Cicero
you